how's it going bros my name is paper
we're gonna play some games today big
surprise
big shocker this game is called campfire
so there's a game about sitting at a
campfire why don't you come along and
sit next to me okay
let me play here we go
my name is Enrico
I am a squirrel from here
again to take over this game fire
the snow Rosemount on the mountain
tonight not a footprint to be seen a
kingdom of isolation and it looks like
I'm the queen the wind is howling like
this swirling storm inside couldn't keep
it in heaven knows I've tried
don't let the men don't let them see be
a good girl you always have to be duckin
conceal don't conceal don't feel don't
let em die or dad made rsg let it go let
it go can't hold it back again I don't
they don't have that cord oh let it go
let it go let it go turn away and slam
the door
take it up so low
go along alright this is a game alright
alright alright
Wow oh my god what they okay uh what
should I do
like a drink meditate sing and drugs
remember shoes well I think everyone
would see if you did drugs and you
probably get disqualified so I would
just sing what the hell is this alright
what else you do I drugs at least I have
my drugs remember that kids don't
remember that all right all right we're
going we only got one shot do not miss a
chance to blow gotta go quick that's
what they say you only get one shot not
miss the chance to blow this opportunity
don't one-in-a-lifetime you're gonna
lose yourself in the music what am i
doing you go you go man
you gotta go quick yes I believe I love
you daddy I love you daddy son and it
quit itself Wow how is this
deliver food WASD to tilt the tray move
the direction to trace Chilton alright I
feel like I'm gonna throw up you're
fired
best game ever ten out of ten oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] whoopsie oh that was a really
nasty burp smell it okay now I
understand so the food comes here
alright we need to go there oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
all right guys hi how are we doin here
oh it looks like your mom died or she's
an alcoholic
a handbag ass don't be sad your mommy's
an alcoholic worse things in life thanks
for the money
my mum my money oh god geez oh god [ __ ]
Shh what's with all their moms buddy
they keep falling over this is really
creepy in this game look at uh forget
the [ __ ] gold bars anyway [ __ ] it out
all right give me another one ready to
serve Wow
oh my god it's vibrating I think the cow
was still alive when they got to make
these burgers these guys are falling
asleep so I should probably all right
guys you want some food what three gold
bars is that oh you can get you bet that
money oh my god what the [ __ ] is going
over [ __ ] ah no no calm down burgers
I still get stumped I'm down bye guys
shut the [ __ ] up and eat stick a yogurt
up your ass all right
when the [ __ ] is room 863 Oh [ __ ] say
white [ __ ] okay I'm really curious
what's it gonna be my room now Oh are
they high when they made this oh yeah is
this a joke
to see if I will find the room that
doesn't exist because I appreciate that
I can appreciate a man who makes troll
but seriously the [ __ ] sake oh my god
no oh this is some kind of [ __ ] joke
it's the goal of the game just to fight
it's a new room now
I think a screenshot why would I think
is the [ __ ] this game [ __ ] whoever made
it I hope you die
okay let's play my way play game that's
actually [ __ ] cool about that thanks
dad
yeah
whoa let go I'm trying
there it is Wow
the spirit of David I love
feeling
yeah
let's do the dress
I can't drift never mind
this game was called rift
well that was pretty [ __ ] all right well
that was great I hope you enjoyed
watching Wow yo yo I'm a regional champ
just so you know I can walk the dog all
day peep I don't okay what should we
write in my